ah attendez
encore un peu
voilà selon la perspective cette attente
a été vécue différemment pour moi qui
enregistre sa passe très lentement
pour vous qui prenez de votre temps pour
regarder une vidéo sur youtube
ça doit passer encore plus lentement
peut-être que certains ont ri peut-être
que certains se sont même énervé ici le
facteur clé c'est la tante attendre
quelque chose ou s'attendre à quelque
chose au moins à ce qu'il se passe
quelque chose
voilà qui détermine complètement notre
expérience du temps je parie aussi que
l'association l'attend à changer en
fonction de ce qui se passait sur
l'écran ce n'est pas pareil si l'image
est vide et statique
s'il ya un mot écrit ou si elle est
carrément en mouvement
trente secondes de silence ça arrive
tout le temps on ne se rend même pas
compte mais trente secondes de silence à
attendre que du son reviennent attendre
qu'il se passe quelque chose
là c'est un autre délire il se passe un
truc en nous c'est encore pire bien sûr
si l'information attendue est importante
comme le diagnostic d'un médecin
en tout cas là pendant presque une
minute au total vous étiez probablement
tendue dans la tente tendue dans le
silence de la tente
et ça c'est une manière de dilater
l'expérience du temps qu'est ce qui nous
empêche de faire ça plus souvent un peu
tous les jours volontairement
qu'est ce qui nous empêche d'allonger le
temps en écoutant en se rendant
spectateurs passifs en attendant la
prochaine chose qui va arriver c'est une
manière de jouer avec notre expérience
du temps un composant essentiel de
l'existence au même titre que l'espace
mais finalement beaucoup plus malléable
que lui c'est une puissance que nous
avons en nous de pouvoir déformer
l'expérience du temps ce serait
peut-être bête de s'en priver
et au fond c'est quoi attendre qu'est ce
qu'on attend
quand on attend quelque chose
qu'attendiez-vous au début de cette
vidéo
vers quels horizons et chivu tendue dans
ce silence
comme l'écrit maurice blanchot dans son
magnifique livre la tempe l'oubli
l'attendent commence quand il n'y a plus
rien à attendre ni même la fin de la
tente
je vous laisse y penser